alors gérard jugnot gérard jugnot comme
vous êtes un monstre sacré du cinéma
désormais on va vous faire une interview
qui a été écrite par un monstre sacré de
la littérature
marcel proust connais pas mais avant
pour compliquer les choses et mariachis
[Musique]
interview proust mariachis
la députée paris
et à partir de minuit commencé à jouer à
jouer très bons amis
ebru letombe mise
bon bah oui
ou alors il
ibrahim
samat radar au caire
jean
l'orgueil ouais
robert c
rick favori le grand gérer
par dessus tout eu
les mariachis
janvier c'est tout
comment aimeriez vous mourrez à voir
mais pas là
quel est à présent de votre esprit
votre esprit
aux côtés
avez vous dit
tu
ghosn
tu veux
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus